[Music]
two years after her headline-making
divorce from Blake Shelton Miranda
Lambert is now opening up big time the
country stars escape a very candid
interview about her journey and the
cover stories title says it all
no pain no reign
[Music]
Miranda tells Billboard that anything
you want to know about her divorce from
Blake is on her album the weight of
these weeds
quote if you want to hear my side of the
story or my opinion of what happened
it's all on there take from it what you
will maybe in fact Miranda co-wrote this
song Vice the day the divorce news broke
Randa says quote I was like let's feel
it all I was ready to have the days
where I can't even stand up and the days
where I'm celebrating we should be
friends Miranda says she went through a
flurry of songwriting over 70 songs
after the split the album has just been
certified platinum two of its songs were
written by Miranda's boyfriend of a year
and a half anderson e's
Maranda slight certainly has changed
quote I won't look at things ever again
in the same light
I won't take pain for granted anymore
[Music]